not everybody is reacting to Saudi
Arabia's brutal killing of Jamal
khashoggi by siding with the Saudis and
saying well they buy stuff from us and
the crown prince very strongly denied
any involvement despite the fact that
the CIA claims to have the guy on an
audio recording saying that Khashoggi
must be silenced which is what Donald
Trump has done so far the rear actually
are some people taking it seriously
Germany Finland Denmark are all going to
stop weapons sales to Saudi Arabia over
this just total disaster disgusting
behavior
criminal behavior by Saudi Arabia
Germany and Denmark are saying that it's
the khashoggi killing that explains why
they are cutting weapons sales to Saudi
Arabia then you have Finland saying it's
actually more related to the
humanitarian crisis in Yemen where the
Saudis are responsible for tens of
thousands of deaths at minimum in Yemen
Denmark's foreign minister actually said
that he thinks they can get more
momentum going to get more European
countries to follow suit and cut ties
with Saudi Arabia at least when it comes
to selling them weapons so let's take it
piece by piece
this is great news this is the right
decision this is what more countries
should be doing the downside and you can
probably guess where I'm going with this
is that the United States alone sells
way more weapons to Saudi Arabia then
all of these countries combined the
United States just did this very big
Trump loved at three hundred and fifty
billion dollars per year I'm sorry
three hundred and fifty billion ten year
deal that is ten billion dollars I'm
sorry thirty five billion dollars per
year for a comparison Germany was
planning on doing about five hundred
million in 2017 Denmark did about seven
hundred and fifty million so it's still
a huge amount of money but what these
countries were doing in terms of arms
deals with Saudi Arabia is like a drop
in the bucket compared to the United
States but still the strategy here
should be one that it's sort of similar
to how you deal with bullies in school
imagine all the bullies all the
authoritarian theocracies and extremists
we've got Kim jong-un and Bashar
al-assad and Duterte and
president G to some degree turkeys air
Dewan Putin the Saudi royal family on
and on the Saudis are like the bullies
in school that people still sucked up to
because they've got access to the beer
or they're the gatekeepers to the cool
parties or whatever analogy you want to
use so with some of the bullies people
take a different approach but with Saudi
Arabia everybody wants to remain friends
because of their role in their position
it's time to make it unappealing to
remain on the good side of Saudi Arabia
right deflate the impetus to stay on
Saudi Arabia's good side if Finland and
Germany and Denmark saying we are no
longer gonna do business with Saudi
Arabia if that leads to more European
countries saying hey you know what we
also want nothing to do with Saudi
Arabia that will keep putting pressure
on the United States now will Trump care
I have no idea a few questions that keep
coming up that are important here are
number one why does Saudi Arabia need to
buy weapons from other countries they
have so much money why don't they just
build whatever weapons they want it
turns out it's actually really difficult
to develop these programs from scratch
and to start building the weapons
themselves requires a crazy amount of
investment and time they have the money
to just buy them from other people and
they have so many other countries
willing to sell so why wouldn't they
just do it that way
number two why do people sell weapons to
Saudi Arabia to begin with and that's a
sort of more complicated story it
relates to Saudi Arabia as one of the
few NATO allies in the region which
explains a lot about why this isn't
going well when Saudi Arabia is one of
your main allies in an entire region
that's not the best position to be in
and in the end if the United States and
the UK keep selling to Saudi Arabia
nothing big is going to change you know
when you look at the top countries that
sell weapons to Saudi Arabia Pat it's
the US the UK France Spain Italy Canada
then it's Germany and Finland and
Denmark
even on that top 10 list altogether so
it's symbolic it's important we should
applaud it but you need some of these
bigger players to say we're going to
stop as well yeah I think American
defense contractors look at the story
and are actually happy because now they
have fewer competitors I certainly don't
think this this will affect Trump's
penchant for Saudi Arabia or the current
arms deal but if anything maybe if we
get a Democratic president in office in
2020 they'll try to cut some of the ties
that we've had with Saudi Arabia for
decades at this point because they'll
see the Khashoggi killing and they'll
see Germany and Finland and Denmark and
all these other countries pulling away
and realized that we have to - maybe but
I'm skeptical I mean even unfortunately
this so areas where Democrats and
Republicans are very different areas
where Democrats and Republicans are not
so different and of course there's no
doubt that you see more Democrats saying
hey listen this is we've got to end this
but you still have a lot of Democrats
who are going to make criticisms of
Saudi Arabia's actions but they're still
going to pay maintain the military
industrial complex we have they know
that these contractors have a lot of
jobs that will provide tax revenue to
even blue states as well and one of the
most disgusting elements of this to me
is that the Khashoggi killing is
horrible it's a tragedy
it's disgusting but most countries
haven't done a thing as Saudi Arabia has
been killing tens of thousands of people
in Yemen one journalist dies and all of
a sudden they're outraged they're right
to be outraged about Jamal khashoggi but
where have they been
during what has been taking place in
Yemen both are outrageous but it's been
outrageous for a very long time